hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are chatting about WWDC
predictions and some of the latest
iPhone 8 rivers that just came across
there's some new leaked images of a
potential iPhone 8 and what can we
expect that will be announced at the WDC
this Monday I'm so excited because last
year at WWDC there wasn't that much that
was announced so this year is supposed
to be the big deal there's so many
potential new hardware announcements
software announcements Theory speaker
iphone 7s iphone 8 macbook upgrades my
fingers crossed at a Mac Pro
announcement
I feel like this WWDC will not
disappoint I've got a bit of a
confession to make so I don't think I'm
going to be able to watch the
announcement so that's what I'm going to
need you guys I need you to tweet me
information any great to let me know as
things are happening I don't know if I
did you guys notice that I'm actually a
really huge tool fan I've been a fan
since early high school and they
regularly toured last time was three
years ago when I made my sister fly to
San Francisco with me to go see them and
when they do it's like a big deal I'm in
Pittsburgh right now and I'm going to
see them in my hometown I couldn't be
more excited I mean I'm seriously so
excited that I'm skipping an Apple
announcement to go see tool so if
there's any other tools fans out there
that I think that you can sympathize
with me and the rest of us is a big deal
I'm going to need you to tweet me and
let me know everything that is happening
as is happening you can follow me on
twitter at iJustine if you're not
already now let's get into some of the
good stuff and why you guys are here so
of course my trusted Mac rumors I love
you guys so much iOS 11 Mac OS 10 13 new
versions of watch OS and TV OS a 10.5
inch iPad pro group and a Siri speaker
before we talk about that we have to
discuss there was this guy on reddit
saying he had insider information on the
next 12 months of hardware updates
there's an Apple glasses project which
would be apples they are sort of
augmented reality type glasses which
says here is potentially delayed or
maybe cancelled I have really seen much
about Apple glasses at all I don't see
your glasses release date yes people are
sort of talking about it but hasn't
actually been on my radar Pirie what's
this on my nose
the rumors surrounding an apple a
hourglasses product honestly I'm not
sure if this is something that if
they're really going to focus on at
least not right now so it definitely
makes sense if it is something that is
delayed if they make a are glasses or
something super cool because I love the
snapchat specs and I actually do wear
glasses so if there was some sort of
cool prescription glasses it actually
looked just like my actual glasses so I
could take photos and talk to my phone
you better believe I'll probably be
first in line for that MacBook at 2018
updates with smart see technology
designed a smart keyboard that can be
customized to accommodate any language
shortcut or custom icon oh that's right
it we did discuss this before in
previous video so just imagine like the
Nook or the Kindle those types of
ereader ink that would be essentially on
a keyboard so as you change the language
the keyboard would also change the keys
to accommodate whatever language that is
and that's pretty cool but not really
sure how necessary it is it's cool but
is it necessary
iOS 11 is Apple is rumored to be working
on social networking assets similar to
Facebook snapchat and Instagram focusing
on giving users a way to share video
make 8at doodles and send to friends I
feel like if Apple did make a social
network and they made it right it would
have a huge potential if it's something
that's already built into your phone it
works perfectly with your iPhone and the
software and everything else that goes
into it it's a no-brainer
if they don't mess it up it could be
beautiful the issue with that though is
will it be backwards compatible so will
you be able to use this new social
network on all iOS devices no matter
what software version you're running I
do think they did a pretty good job with
Eclipse app but I haven't really used it
very much because most of the video
editing that I do I do it in Final Cut
Pro so anything that I want I do it on
there
and then send it to my phone the second
iteration of Mac OS operating system
which was updated from the traditional
OSX but it will undoubtedly feature
another name the reflex the California
landscape and let me tell you what guys
I just recently went to Yosemite and one
of the reasons that I wanted to go to
Yosemite yes you guessed it because of
Mac OSX Yosemite when they updated it to
El Capitan let me tell you where I
wanted to go he was on my first two
duelists at Yosemite was to go visit it
so we're here
made it my goal has been complete that
our out copy dogs don't get well yeah
well begun right bye
[Applause]
so the OS updates the TV and watch very
smart speaker this is what we came for
at least that's what I came for
so how about you guys I would love to
know which home speaker you guys used
you have a LexA or do you have Google
home do you have something else that I'm
not even aware about I sort of used them
both in different situations and I can't
really say what those situations are I
think it's just when I happen to be like
hey Alexa what's on my shopping list hey
Google set a timer for 15 minutes I feel
like I use Alexa more for shopping and
Google more for asking questions so what
would the series speaker look like so
the same redditor also had distance'
regarding apple's rumor Siri based
speaker reportedly housed a nine
processor can all be about the same size
as apples trash can mac pro design
what's that mean the good old size of a
pro the mac pro designs was pretty cool
so I would definitely be okay with that
as to whether on the device will include
a screen the leaker notes that Apple
chess just three different designs one
of which did not have a screen so if
they have three different design than
two of them did have a screen my bets
would be on it having a screen unless
they launched the first one without a
screen and then the one with the screen
will be the later iteration I feel like
they're going to have some competition
with the Amazon Alexa show but of
Amazon's latest Alexa release and it
kind of looks like a little like baby
monitor type thing i pre-ordered it so
don't worry we will definitely have an
unboxing in full review when it comes in
iPhone 8 what new features will Apple
add we've discussed all of this before
but some of the latest leaks have said
that it's been pretty much confirmed
that Apple will not have the touch ID
button built in to the glass it will
have a full front glass screen but the
touch ID looks like it will be in the
back home button reports a correct Apple
will eliminate the physical home button
so it'll be a lot like the Galaxy s8
where the home button is built into the
screen what is totally fine because it
works great on the f8 and I'm sure it
works great on the essay and Apple is
going to also do an incredible job at
man I'm just wishing they could build
the touch ID into the screen on the
front it would be just beautiful fingers
crossed and hopefully but that's what
they're going to go for price in relief
chain so a lot of the stuff I've covered
in previous videos there hasn't been
that much new news that's been out since
the last video that I posted the drawing
above appears to align closely with the
similar iPhone 8 rumors we've seen over
the past few days and should be a close
approximation on the device the Apple
will actually ship later this year you
guys can see
that there was a lot of discussion that
they're now going to be having the
camera be a vertical camera so these
right here are the two camera lenses one
and two and with the flash in the middle
so it'll be sort of the same thing that
we have now with the iPhone 7 plus
you've got your go cameras in the flash
but they're just gonna turn it and throw
the flash in the middle here we've got a
couple versions of oh my goodness are
you dog hi come here I am making a movie
I'm making you video do you like oh okay
okay
it's okay that you came in here you
wanted to see you wanted to be next to
me that's my sister's dog he gets a
little um yeah it is a pretty cool
drawing this shows where the iPhone
eight would land in a lineup of other
phones so here it is right here and this
would be the iPhone 7 this is the pixel
here's the Galaxy s8 iPhone 7 plus and
down here this is the middle render that
they think that will be the new iPhone 8
it looks like there might be two cameras
in the front I'm not quite sure if
that's what I'm seeing that would be
pretty interesting if they did decide to
put a dual camera in the front no
complaints here I thought a design like
digital touch ID on the back is likely
fake this basically just looks like they
copy and pasted at the front home button
and stuck it on the back it's very very
similar to that of being a pixel this
looks really nice a very very slicked
back
I mean there is nothing on it there's no
logos there's no nothing yeah not so
into that a lot of people are saying
that this potentially could have been
Apple prototype that they've already
thrown out the window and said nope this
is not happening let's do one last check
and see if there's anything else new
that we may have missed if there's
anything that you guys have heard feel
free to also leave that in the comments
below I always love reading through the
discussions after I post these videos
because you guys have so many great
ideas and I really love seeing what you
guys are most looking forward to
hardware is always a given a w-c-c
number now so 2016 they announced iOS 10
sierra watching us 3 in TV OS it was
sort of a slower watc last year while i
look forward to seeing what happens on
Monday and again please tweet me leave
me comments here Instagram you Facebook
me and let me know as the event is
happening what's happening
I will be enjoying my tool concert and
until then I will see you guys back here
on Tuesday that's when I'll be hosting
my full wrap-up video of everything that
happened on Monday at the event a recap
my reaction and what I think about what
they else so I'll see you guys later bye
[Music]